[Music]
white corn is one of our relatives we
feel that she is alive she wants to do
the job that she told our creator she
would do is to feed our people to
nourish them the work that we do if we
didn't have this we would lose
everything
[Music]
for a few thousand years Potawatomi
people have been incredible farmers and
have grown lots and lots of varieties of
crops the seed library is a place where
we take crops which are disappearing
rare and endangered Potawatomi
vegetables and we grow them out and we
restore them and put them back in the
hands of native farmers
[Music]
George Martin carries the Potawatomi
tradition of making Dom Nabu or corn
soup in our seed library we have 76
unique varieties of corn each one has
its own cultural identity its own unique
flavor after a while when we stir it
you'll see how tough it gets to stir it
our corn is a lot different than other
corns which are out there if we didn't
have the seed library these traditional
food might be gone forever within our
seed library 80% of the varieties which
we take care of our rare or nearly
extinct some of the varieties we care
for here we're the only place in the
world which has them this one's going to
be a nice one four years ago when we
first got another signal at our white
flour corn we only had a half a canning
jar a very small amount of seed we've
grown it every year since and now we
have enough that we may have a hundred
bushels fall that's enough that next
year we can plant six or seven acres of
just this corn that's a huge increase
it is important mutate that's what we
are sent down here for to take care of
Mother Earth and all her creations here
and that corn realizes that we're back
using it again that we're going to use
it in the feast makes the corn feel good
after being used by our people again its
gun is ready to eat
you